Even Arnold came out against Donald Trump,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
he was married talking
about he was nice with them.
That was nice of them.
I gave them to sausage.
Can Trump.
He said,
dude,
in his voice,
I can no longer stand for
someone I know of a scumbag.
Then myself,
there's a line people.
He had just crossed it.
Okay.
John grabbed a pussy.
First of all,
a lot of them will let you do.
You just have to ask.
Just grabbing pussy left.
Do like grabbing pussy.
You're pro Hillary.
Hillary is a good woman.
She's just misunderstood.
Sometimes people when they
are around good women,
they wind up suiciding themselves.
[inaudible] personalities is,
it makes you humble.
Governor.
That was our governor.